gaia wrote in saying david there's lots
of talk about quote mental health in the
US especially related to gun safety how
would you improve the mental health
system in the united states this is like
a really big question and i want to talk
about it not really related to guns
because the gun issue is a specific
issue but let's talk more generally
there is still a huge amount of stigma
in the united states about so-called
mental illness and I say so-called
because it has a very particular
implication even though you know someone
who suffers from like generalized
anxiety disorder is in a sort of strict
sense someone with a quote mental
illness in the same way that a cold is a
physical illness just because something
counts as a mental illness or physical
illness doesn't mean that someone is so
incapacitated that they can't be sort of
well adjusted members of society right
so I think one thing is it has to be
significantly D stigmatized the other
thing relates to health insurance and
the health insurance status quo that we
have screws up so much of mental health
and there's something called a diagnosis
code and when someone goes to see a
mental health professional in order to
receive covered treatment from their
insurer the mental health provider needs
to diagnose the individual with some
condition and there's been this sort of
catch-all that has been developed which
i think is called my dad was telling me
about it
who's in mental health I think it's
called like general adjustment disorder
or something like that and it basically
just means life you're dealing with life
right you're having some difficulty
adjusting to some reality of what it
means to be human and exist in the world
but big picture these diagnosis codes
are sort of used to limit the amount the
number of sessions that people can have
and to generate requirements for
providers to on an ongoing basis
continue justifying exactly why this is
someone whose treatment should be
reimbursed
I believe that mental health needs to be
taken sort of out of that part of health
insurance and put more into these sort
of general wellness and proof
of care side where we should be
encouraging people to take advantage of
mental health services with the idea
that over the long term those are going
to be healthier people less likely to
become sick with conditions that can be
psychogenic or psychosomatic as a result
of stress and anxiety in their lives
less likely to end up maybe needing to
go on expensive psychiatric medications
etc so that I think that those are some
big picture changes that need to happen
one is very specific within health
insurance the other is more of a
cultural thing it's just around the
stigma of mental health I don't know if
you have anything else big or if you
agree disagree with that I mean these
are all how do you change stigma at
large in culture right I mean it's a
really difficult thing and even when we
have a shooting and there's just this
phrase don't mental illness mental
illness well just because somebody saw a
therapist four years ago and then later
they go in and commit an act of violence
doesn't necessarily mean that whatever
brought them to the therapist four years
ago is to blame and that's a problem I
worried that could be counterproductive
too because maybe someone who wants to
hold on to their guns also is
experiencing depression or some a
beautiful illness absolutely and so
they're averse to going to professional
to help them like a therapist yep
they're averse to taking antidepressants
because then they think the government's
gonna come after their guns sure and
they'd rather have that that is
shockingly and maybe not shockingly but
depressingly common in the military
where in the military it is known that
if you go and seek help for certain
things it's not going to be good for
your military career and of course that
creates situations and the military is
trying to change this culture it creates
situations where people will get worse
because they're not seeking treatment
for something because they don't want to
end up losing their position in the
military and I think that you're
pointing to something that also exists
in the general population I think we've
come a long way though I remember in the
70s well I wasn't there but no battles
sure George McGovern president I think
in 1972 his running mate
had like electroshock there yeah as a
way to treat his depression maybe he
took some SSRIs - that's right and they
had to take
off of the ticket yeah place him because
of the stigma behind mental health
that's right and I recently read fear
and loathing on the campaign trail by
Hunter S Thompson and there's a couple
chapters devoted to that entire thing
and how there was probably a mishandling
of it from the beginning in part just
because of how there were constantly
miss handlings of things related to
mental health at the time